- What?
(quiet yay)
(cute electronic music)
- Whatcha got there?
Hello, darling humans, I'm Hannah,
and I haven't quite figured out
what I'm gonna do to intro this.
But in the last couple
of videos we've done,
we post a number that you guys can text me
to say any ideas that you
have for future episodes,
and it was very clear
what you guys wanted,
and so we're gonna give it to you today.
I let my kids dress me for a whole week.
It was very fun, it was very
weird, and I learned a lot.
So first, as always, I needed
to lay some ground rules,
most importantly so I
didn't get arrested in this
experiment for, like, public
indecency or something.
First rule was I needed
to be fully clothed.
There was going to be no
underwear in place of pants,
or bathing suit tops in place of shirts,
or underwear on my head as a hat.
Because I have two boys,
they think it's very funny.
So second, I tried to give them
equal opportunity to each choose an outfit
for those of you who understand
what life is like with two boys.
There's a lot of conflict around sharing,
so I just straight up delegated days
to each kid so that it
wasn't an hour of them
like, arguing over who got to pick what.
And third, I had to do
this for seven days,
and I had to follow through
with whatever outfit they chose,
within reason, and I
immediately regretted that.
(laughs)
Day one of these boys
picking out my clothes.
So day one, I decided
Jaxon would pick my outfit
because he's pretty stylish, he likes to
dress himself, he kind of knows
how to coordinate outfits, and that day,
I happened to have a friend in town
who was visiting and so I was taking her
to the Getty Villa in Malibu, and we were
gonna be around a lot of people
because it's a big tourist attraction.
So right off the bat, he picks the top,
and he chooses this off the shoulder
kind of billowy, flowy,
pink and black tie-dyed top
that I actually just
bought recently and I love.
That shirt? Okay.
What he chose for the bottoms were
these children's Old
Navy size large shorts
that I'd gotten at a
children's thrift store
and they are baby blue
with white polka dots.
Oh my God.
- Now get dressed!
(Hannah laughs)
- I looked like a spotted, deranged
Oompa Loompa in this outfit.
I keep forgetting that I'm wearing this
and people keep staring at me and I think
that they're staring at my hair
and then I realize it's ...
just this.
(her friend giggles)
Let me tell you no one was
looking at the art that day.
They were looking at my outfit.
That was a pretty ridiculous way
to start out the experiment.
It was kind of like my worst fears
all coming true on day one.
So, day two, I gave Jaxon
a chance to redeem himself.
We needed a do-over, so
he chose a really cute
romper that I love and actually gave me
a hoodie to wear too, which I was
excited about because it
was chilly out that day.
So I left the house feeling very happy
in my cute romper until
I remembered one thing.
I totally forgot that today I have
a doctor's appointment, and TMI,
but it's a female doctor's appointment
where you have to undress
from the waist down.
You girls out there know the struggle
of trying to, like, pee in a romper.
You have to just take everything off
and like get completely
naked in the stall.
I was about to have to do
that in the doctor's office.
So I have a t-shirt that I'm gonna bring
into the office to change when they
ask me to take my clothes
off from the waist down.
And as if it's not awkward enough
to go to like the lady doctor,
it would've been so much more awkward
if she came back in the room and
I was like, "Hey, it's me, naked."
So day two, you know,
it was a cute outfit.
It's just when you're having someone else
pick out your clothes,
they're not thinking
of what your day is going to be,
especially when they're five years old.
So day three, Jaxon's choice once again.
I think he was in kind of a weird mood
because he chose this random t-shirt
for me to wear, and it's
like a yellow t-shirt
with a girl on a motorcycle, and it says
Motorcycle: put something
exciting between your legs.
He doesn't know how to read!
And then he chose these kinda silly
floral shorts to pair with it.
- This is what you should wear.
- Those? All right.
We don't have much of
a dress code at work,
and it's pretty casual because it's
a creative environment and we're allowed
to kind of like wear
what makes us comfortable
but this was just like, I felt weird
walking in the door, but luckily,
that day, Jaxon was
coming to work with me,
and he decided, for
himself, he wanted to wear
some Halloween costume
werewolf hands to work with me.
I got a weird kid, what can I say.
So at least we looked ridiculous together.
Rolling up on day four, I don't know
what to expect at this point,
it was Wyatt's choice today.
So first he tried to choose the romper
that I'd already worn, but I vetoed that
because I figured this experiment
is best with seven separate outfits.
So instead, he chose a jumpsuit
that I bought on sale
online without trying on
and then it arrived and it fit,
then the second I washed it, it shrank,
and it was like way too tight.
Way too tight!
Since it was really tight, if I wore
any underwear under it, it would've shown.
So I had no choice but to go commando
and with that being said,
I had to tie a sweater
around my waist to avoid
any cameltoe mishaps,
'cause I was going to work in this.
Leave it to Wyatt to almost make me expose
all of my parts to everybody at work.
So day five was finally the first
collaborative effort between both kids,
and they actually ended
up dressing me head to toe
because they got so involved in this,
they decided they had to pick my shoes.
So Jaxon and Wyatt collectively chose
this really beautiful blue dress
that I really enjoy wearing and then
Jaxon just had to pull out
some sort of wild card.
- These I want you to wear.
- That dress and my PJ shorts.
According to Jaxon, you can't
wear a dress without bottoms.
Don't know where he's getting these
fashion rules, but he ended up choosing
the most bulky pair of pajama shorts I own
for me to wear under it.
It was a very bulky day.
Very bulky day.
How do you like my outfit, Jaxon?
Do you still like it?
- Good.
- Good?
Let's see what Daddy thinks.
Dee, what do you think of my outfit?
- I love it.
- So day six, almost at the end,
and day six was straight
up Wyatt's time to shine.
And I think he had
spent the past five days
really thinking about what he wanted
because the second I told him he could
choose my outfit, he just bolted
to this random knit poncho that I've had
hanging in my closet for years.
This?
- This.
- This poncho?
Okay.
Oh yeah, jump on it, and make sure
it's nice and worn in, right?
He ends up deciding on some
denim cutoffs to pair with it.
I looked like I was ready for
an evening Coachella show.
Whoo-hoo, Coachella!
My kids are gonna look
back on this and watch it
and be like, holy crap,
Mom, you're embarrassing.
- Kendrick Lamar on the main stage!
I just realized that this whole experiment
with having my kids dress me has forced me
to wake up a lot earlier because usually
I just like throw on whatever the first
thing I grab is, out
of my closet, but they
actually like to take their
time choosing my outfits,
so I'm exhausted, I'm really tired.
So day seven, the grand finale.
I decided that I wanted you guys
to experience this with me live,
so today is actually my day seven outfit.
It is brought to you 100% by Jaxon.
He dressed me head to toe this time,
and I think he kinda wanted
to go out with a bang
because he was very adamant about
picking something a little more
formal for me and kept saying,
"Mom, you gotta look nice,
you gotta look nice."
and today, I got a lot of
compliments from my coworkers.
- Oh, damn, Hannah.
- [Hannah] What?
- You look super cute.
I don't know if I just
generally dress crappy
or if this past week
has been so ridiculous.
You know, Jaxon dressed me.
(happy squeal)
- Oh my God, can he dress me?
(laughing) He's styling.
- So after a week of like
really all over the place
outfits, real hit and
misses, Jaxon comes through
on day seven, and I feel
really good about myself.
I don't know how to model.
What do you do with your hands?
So what did I learn this week?
Well, I actually learned a whole lot more
than I thought I would.
First and foremost, I need
to clean out my dang closet.
The fact that these items like the poncho,
the jumpsuit, and the polka dot shorts
were in my closet and in my drawers,
that's on me, that's my fault.
The second thing I learned is that I could
afford to spend some more
time choosing my outfits.
I think a lot of you moms
out there can also relate.
The morning is mostly spent making sure
that my children are
fully clothed and dressed
and then I'm kind of an afterthought,
but I realized I go to work, I see people,
I need to look presentable.
So it's important for me to
spend some time on myself
and my outfit and make sure that
I feel confident and look nice.
And the final thing I learned is that
I don't give a crap
what anyone else thinks,
and that is something that I've noticed--
(bird caws)
Hello.
And the thing thing that I learned
is that I don't give a crap
what anyone else thinks of me.
(bird caws)
What?!
And this is something that I've realized
since having kids, you're so concerned
about all this other stuff,
what other people think of you,
and how other people are seeing you,
is kind of your last priority as a parent
but being at the Getty,
wearing that ridiculous
outfit, having everybody
staring at me, was fine.
I mean, I had to keep reminding myself
that I was wearing something weird,
and that's why everyone was looking,
because I didn't even
notice and I did not care.
So if you are a parent and you're not
feeling the most confident, have your kid
dress you for a day, go out in public,
and just be like, "Screw you, everybody,
"this is what I'm wearing and I'm happy."
So that's all I got for today.
I'm Hannah and I absolutely loved
trying this, I loved this idea.
I love hearing what you guys wanna see
so please send me more
ideas, leave them in the
comments or text me,
this is a real number.
I read every text, I
don't reply to all of them
because I get a lot, but I do read
every text that you guys send,
and I love hearing what
you guys wanna see.
Now, if you'll excuse me, I'm gonna go
change into sweatpants and a t-shirt.
(laughs) 'Cause that's me.
'Til next time!
Can you smile, Wyatt?
(gentle jazzy music)
Oh yeah, you have the best smile.